all right so this is a frontiers
airlines um
they're stewardesses flight attendants
had to duct tape this person through
their chair
if you if you act up that's their best
bet how do they not have handcuffs or
some [ __ ] i don't know
i mean it's super fast though
it takes i don't know 10 minutes yeah
grown man yeah just watch it
so this is them doug is he fighting him
because the mask no
they're all laughing i know
that didn't look like duct tape that's a
different kind of tape packing tape yeah
that can't be allowed yeah they keep
doing it to people though well so that
what this guy did was he
he was obviously like you know mouthing
off to people because he was drunk
he spilled something on his shirt went
to the bathroom then he came out with a
shirt off
and then then the flight attendants were
helping him put another shirt from his
bag
on and then i guess he groped two of
them and then oh
fought another one so they had to do
something yeah so they used could do
something now did they usually just
cause a mask
like the the assault on flight
attendants through the roof because yeah
and did they get him um what is this
this is the guy by the way
max barry and they they they taped his
mouth shut too yeah his mouth
that seems excessive but i mean this
guy's a douchebag
how could he get out did he get in
trouble though well what if he was
spitting on you
yeah okay but like how did he not
is this the kid who's yelling about his
uh yeah his parents are worth two
million dollars
he's fighting him here
i like this guy's not [ __ ] my parents
were two million dollars
they're like in the middle seat in the
back they're all on them
so they're suspended but that's just
like routine they're not going to get
fired or anything
it's just they're not paid leave they're
on paid leave yeah okay the flight
attendant oh they should they should
they should get bonus
exactly yeah this [ __ ] was
tripping that guy's a dick i wish that
[ __ ] would happen on my flight
brendan they see you they don't want to
go you go in there and just come to
school smother them
just anaconda you know when they're
anaconda's here is anybody
on board a doctor and there you know
there might be one yeah and that's like
is anybody
does anybody have any experience in
fighting
can you do this and i'd like is it
travis brown like king velazquez like no
i'm like
can you do it just come on did somebody
call them anaconda
somebody called a man and just [ __ ]
scrap him off i take my shirt
like what are you taking a shirt off
like i don't wanna cause i'm gonna
because i'm gonna suffocate him in my
tits as
you said like sir can you hurry i'm like
i'm scratching